cette auberge de jeunesse a été
transformé en centre d'accueil pour les
ukrainiens fuyant la guerre
notre peuple se bat là-bas ma mère est
là bas et je suis ici mais nous avons
décidé de partir pour le bien des
enfants j'ai dit à mon mari que nous
devions les emmener pour ne pas qu'ils
voient ce cauchemar mais pour rejoindre
le royaume uni un premier obstacle
administratif se présente l'obtention
d'un visa sauf qu'il n'ya pas d'antenne
consulaire à calais il faut retourner à
paris où aller à bruxelles
la maire de calais dénonce l'attitude
des britanniques on peut pas dire d'un
côté on les accueille et puis on peut
pas non plus regarder
et voir ces personnes qui il ya huit
jours était encore chez elle qui voit
les missiles tombent et sur leurs
habitations et puis des britanniques
qu'ils nous disent mais on vous
accueille et puis au bout du compte non
on vous fermez appartenait la grande
bretagne accusés de lenteur peu
compréhensibles par la france vient
d'annoncer l'ouverture dans les
prochains jours d'un second centre de
demande de visa dans l'hexagone après
celui de paris il sera installé dans le
nord à lille londres qui assure faire
tout son possible a indiqué lundi soir
qu'au total près de 18000 demandes
d'immigration ukrainienne avait été
soumise au titre du regroupement
familial seules quelques centaines de
visa ont pour l'heure été délivrés